Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Carl Sagan was an American scientists
known for his work as a science educator,
but he was not merely a teacher.
His vision was to get average people
interested in science and emphasize the
importance of scientific knowledge and
understanding and all roles of life from
politics and economics to quality
of life and general wellbeing.
His most famous works stressing this
philosophy and quit a number of books such
as the demon haunted world
and the dragons of Eden.
And of course his famous TV series cosmos.
Carl Sagan believed that abandoning
science in the modern age could lead to
catastrophe. So in this video we're
going to look at 10 pieces of advice.
He left us on how to build a society,
which does not make such a mistake.
So let's get to it.
Number 10 people are not stupid.
They believe things can reasons.
The last way for skeptics that get
the attention of bright, curious,
intelligent people is to belittle or
condescend or to show arrogance toward
their beliefs. Oftentimes the truth tends
to come into conflict with religious,
political,
philosophical,
common sense notions or previously how
scientific thought of how the world works.
People are not always so ready
to give up these beliefs.
Their values and opinions are not always
as flexible as a scientist should be.
It is clear that Carl Sagan believes
wholeheartedly and embracing the truth,
but he cautions that there was a
professional and mature way to go about
introducing the truth.
Average people may disagree with something
otherwise logical simply because they
view it as the opinion of the enemy.
Seginus argues is that relating to them
and showing respect for them and their
beliefs while introducing it,
perhaps painful truth to them,
we'll make it somewhat less painful and
you'll find them to be less abrasive.
Number nine,
if it can be destroyed by the truth,
it deserves to be destroyed by the truth.
While Carl Sagan suggests a nonaggressive
and mature approach to debate and
discussion,
he does not believe that the truth
should be surrendered to fit people's
conceptions of the world.
What is true is true because it has been
shown to be true and in the realm of
science.
The only reasonable grounds to say that
something is not true is to prove it
otherwise. That's the end of
the story. Number eight for me,
it is far better to grasp the universe
as it really is then to persist in
delusion,
however satisfying and reassuring.
This is closely related to the last
quote and that Sagan is again reiterating
that the truth is to be
held in the highest regard.
It is very unwise to hide
behind the comfortable life,
especially in circumstances
where understanding the
truth is of great importance
to our lives.
Typically hearing these quotes,
we may imagine a creationist or something
advocating their usual arguments.
However,
this way of thinking is useful for
more than just debating creationists on
reddit. We can take this advice
to politics, to our social lives,
to our personal perspectives of ourselves,
to our values and beliefs and apply the
same unwavering respect for the truth as
a means to better ourselves.
Number seven,
the absence of evidence is
not the evidence of absence.
Science demands evidence before
something can be confirmed to exist.
While it would not be wise to be certain
of something such as the existence of
aliens,
which I believe Carl Sagan was speaking
of with regard to this quote originally
before on your found,
there is a good amount of reason to
believe that aliens may in fact exist if
there is no evidence for or against
something than science has no opinion on
whether or not something
does or does not exist,
and the question then is worth
pursuing further. Number six,
the nuclear arms race is like two sworn
enemy standing waist deep in gasoline,
one with three matches,
the other with five Carl Sagan of course
lived during the Cold War when the
threat of nuclear war between the United
States and the Soviet Union loomed over
the world.
Carl Sagan regarded such a thing as
nuclear war as one of the most dangerous
consequences of avoiding science and
reason regardless of what one might think
up to two sides and their
disagreement to these disagreements.
Being settled over a nuclear war had the
potential to reduce huge parts of the
entire world to ruins even the victor of
such a war with suffer the consequences
of a fractured civilization and
utterly destroyed global environment.
While Sagan completely agreed that a more
peaceful solution to the problems that
the world powers face is ideal.
This is a perfect example of why world
powers understanding science could be
crucial to avoiding disaster.
Number five,
science is a way of thinking much
more than it is a body of knowledge.
Many of these codes have
been suggesting this point.
Science is more than an encyclopedia
of colorful insects and violence stars.
The scientific method or more broadly
and understanding of the philosophy of
empiricism introduces a new
way of thinking about the
world with an emphasis on,
you guessed it, what is true, factual,
correct, and things of that nature,
even if it is uncomfortable. Number
four, the cosmos is within us.
We are made of star stuff. We are
away for the universe to know itself.
Carl Sagan also famously said, the
nitrogen and our DNA, the calcium and rts,
the iron in our blood,
the carbon and our apple pies were made
in the interiors of collapsing stars.
One of cross sagans must
important arguments for why
we should pay attention to
the entire universe around us and
endeavor to understand it is that we are
inescapably a part of it and subject
to the forces that governance,
we are not separate from the universe.
We are the universe as well,
and that perspective can change
things quite a bit. Number three,
the fact that some geniuses were laughed
at does not imply that all who are
laughed at our geniuses, they laughed
at Columbus. They laughed at Fulton,
they laughed at the Wright brothers,
but they also laughed at Bozo.
The clown science is filled with tales
of great minds whose work was originally
disrespected and disregarded even though
it turned out to be true and quite
profound in the end.
Such stories encourage people to stand
in the face of unwarranted criticism and
defense of the facts.
However,
a downside to this is that people may
be reluctant to catch on when their work
is. In fact, not all that credible.
Don't jump the gun just because something
seems profound. It might be ridiculous.
Number two,
we live in a society exquisitely dependent
on science and technology in which
hardly anyone knows anything
about science and technology.
Consider for a moment all the
objects and forces around you,
all the tools you use and the things
you do throughout the day and how you do
them. Many of these things
may only function and appear
in the ways that they do
because of scientific understanding.
That took centuries to arrive to the
loss of such knowledge and a lack of
respect for the science that brought
these things and lifestyles to us.
It could have caused them to never have
existed in a ways have to do the loss of
such knowledge and the lack of respect
for the science that brought these things
in.
Lifestyles to us could have caused them
to have never existed in a way is that
they do consider the gravity of the
situation in the near future where things
like robotics in genetic engineering
and things of that nature become more
serious threats and the public
has no idea how they work.
This is already an issue in today's world.
Number one,
look again at that dot that's here.
That's home.
That's us on it. Everyone
you love, everyone you know,
everyone you ever heard of every human
being who ever was lived out their lives.
Carl Sagan said that astronomy was a
humbling field of the many ways we view
ourselves and our place in
the grand scheme of things.
One of the most profound was from the
perspective of an image taken from around
Saturn of the earth.
The entire planet appears as
an unimportant blue blemish
in the blackness around
it. Yet on that barely
visible blue.is as he said,
everything that we are,
no human being has ever gone farther
than a Tinier moon that orbits it.
It truly puts into perspective the things
that we do for power, fame, wealth,
glory status,
et Cetera.
Even the greatest empires I've only
ever controlled a fraction of a dot,
which looks like it could just
be rubbed off the picture.
Everyone with an interest in astronomy,
marvels at how small we are,
but this picture really
drives that concept home.
That's not to say that what we have on
this tiny blue.is insignificant. However,
as Carl Sagan also said, every one
of us is an a cosmic perspective.
Precious.
If a human being disagrees with you,
let him live in 100 billion galaxies,
you will not find another.
Even though this thought is
small and seemingly fragile,
the other hundreds of thousands of dots
surrounding it may be completely barren.
The fact that life seems so small and
fragile from this perspective is all the
more reason to cherish and defend
it. Cross Sagan, of course,
had a lot of other things to say,
but these were some of his best quotes.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
we should have checked out, fire learning
and subscribed. Thank you for watching.